und dann gab es natürlich in den letzten
Tagen zwei große Trauerfälle einmal die
Beisetzung der Queen logisch und Sarah
Wagenknecht hat quasi immer Alleingang
die Linkspartei beerdigt also ja
die Partei zuckt noch aber das sind nur
die Nervenenden die die Spaltung heißt
es ist ein reale Option Wagenknecht
spricht im Bundestag vom
Wirtschaftskrieg den wir als Deutschland
gegen Russland vom Zaun gebrochen hätten
muss auch ein Standpunkt manche Kritiker
werfen ihn und vor das wäre lupenreiner
afd-sound das finde ich schon muss ich
sagen sehr weit hergeholt frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir brauchen weiterhin russische
Rohstoffe und russisches Gas das
Problem ist der von Robert Habeck
angezettelte Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
unseren wichtigsten Energielieferanten
schaffen sie Tatsachen und machen Sie
Schluss mit den fatalen
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
wie süß sie beenden schon die Sätze des
anderen toll ich meine natürlich ist
Wagenknecht nicht rechts sie möchte
einfach nur die Fanbase erweitern ihre
Bücher verkaufen sich ja nicht von
alleine im übrigen auch der Linken
Fraktionschef bartsch hat nach der Rede
geklatscht mit der Begründung Applaus
sei ein Zitat Gebot der Höflichkeit
seitdem hört der Zoff bei denen gar
nicht mehr auf und mit dem
Finanzexperten Fabio dimasi und dem
sozial-lobbyisten Ulrich Schneider sind
schon zwei sehr prominente Mitglieder
ausgetreten andere klingen selber wie
kreml-mitarbeiter wenn man verhandeln
will haben beide Positionen die Ukraine
hat die Position sie will das zurück die
Russen haben die Position sie geben es
immer hier aus welchen Gründen auch
immer
ja und der remo-clan gibt die Münze aus
dem bodenmuseum auch nicht mehr her aus
welchen Gründen auch immer
und selbst wenn Frau Wagenknecht nichts
dafür kann ist es zumindest kein gutes
Zeichen wenn der rechtsextreme Jürgen
Elsässer neuerdings klingt wie ihr
Fanboy
damit der in da drüben die Ohren klingen
Sarah Sarah
Franz Becken heute gesagt die Sarah die
kann rechts wie links
das war übrigens neulich in Leipzig was
wir da gerade gesehen haben da haben
tatsächlich die Linken und die Rechten
auf demselben Platz direkt nebeneinander
demonstriert da wusste selbst die Antifa
nicht mehr auf wen sie jetzt die Steine
werfen soll sag mal wer von dem Fahrrad
denn jetzt Deutschland zuerst und
irgendwie beide oh scheiße
Entschuldigung Herr bullenschwein wo
stehen denn jetzt hier die Rechten
rechts oder oder links keine Ahnung also
die da wollen das nordstream 2
aufgemacht wird aber die wollen das auch
ja das nächste kompliziert wer ist okay
wenn wir uns einfach Papst Maul haben
wie früher ja klar okay
man steigt nicht mehr durch wirklich
zu den Tatsachen Sarah Wagenknecht ist
und bleibt eine erfolgreiche ich AG mit
einem wollen wir ihr lassen
unglaublichen Gespür für die gerade
angesagten aufregerthemen ob Zuwanderung
Identitätspolitik impfdiktatur oder
Putin Hauptsache Talkshow Einladung und
das klappt oder oder ist es noch viel
banaler und die Sarah und ihr Mann
zerstören einfach gerne Parteien ja
quasi als Hobby sowie andere Golf
spielen das ist ja so überlegen Sie mal
larford erst die SPD kaputt gemacht und
dann ist er eine Woche vor der
saarlandwahl neulich aus der Linkspartei
ausgetreten und wenn sie sich immer noch
fragen woran damals die Piratenpartei
gestorben ist ganz einfach
[Musik]
gut was die Linkspartei angeht ist das
Timing schon sehr sehr bitter denn die
eigentlichen Themen der Partei werden
immer wichtiger in diesen Tagen aktuelle
Meldungen neuer Höchststand bei der
Kinderarmut die längst versprochene
Kinder Grundsicherung kommt irgendwann
und das neue Bürgergeld auch erst im
Januar aber man kann ja trotzdem schon
mal losheizen wissen Sie wenn einer
nicht arbeiten will gerne wenn einer
gern in der Tonne liegt und die joggen
ist spielt gerne es ist nicht meine
Aufgabe des zu kritisieren aber wenn
einer Geld bekommt von anderen und die
dies bezahlen nicht einmal mehr erwarten
dürfen dass er sich bemüht wenn er das
Geld bekommt dann ist es der falsche Weg
Fleiß und Leistung muss belohnt und
nicht bestraft werden in unserem Land
ja gut manche legen sich in die Tonne
andere halten reden für die Tonne so ist
das normal vor allem die Union warnt
jetzt ständig vor der Hartz IV Reform
und wir schalten mal live zu Münchner
Wiesen dort leitet Birte Schneider die
neue csu-arbeitsgruppe zu Bekämpfung des
bürgergeld-wahnsinns hörte wie ich sehe
machen sie Überstunden ja klar irgendwer
muss ja noch arbeiten in diesem Land
ey ab Januar 50 Euro mehr Stütze Kuckuck
das ist ja wohl sonnenklar was 3 Minuten
später passiert die ganzen Harzer Rennen
direkt zum Zigarettenautomaten und der
Rest wird sinnlos versoffen
ahh
du bist die beste Centi wie sagt man
Kopf tut weh und hotzen Stinker da muss
ich leider Bier drauf trinken ja was ist
das denn bitte für ein Menschenbild dass
ihr Herr Söder da jetzt in die Bierzelte
rülpst die 50 Euro mehr sind ein
überfälliger Inflationsausgleich
500 2 Euro im Monat für nichts Luxus wie
bei den Kardashians oder klar wir dann
keine Sau mehr arbeiten wie wäre es wenn
man mit Eigenverantwortung sich selber
kümmern hier unser Markus macht's vor
wenn seine Frau keinen eigenen
Regenschirm zu Wiesen mitbringt wird sie
eben nass nur so lernt man es
ohne Strafe lernt keiner was deswegen
ist das auch völlig bekloppt beim
Bürgergeld die Sanktionen wegzulassen ja
erstens auch beim Bürgergeld können nach
sechs Monaten bis zu 30 Prozent gekürzt
werden zweitens nur etwa drei Prozent
der Hartz-IV-Empfänger kommen überhaupt
jemals mit Sanktionen in Berührung sie
haben überhaupt nichts kapiert der welke
wir brauchen die Sanktionen doch nicht
für die Harzer sondern damit unsere
Niedriglöhner auch noch irgendwie haben
auf den sie runter gucken können
als Geringverdiener ich wird bekommen
die Wohnung bezahlt ich komme bekommen
den Heizkosten und die Nebenkosten wie
Strom noch bezahlt
dann ist der Anreiz zu arbeiten relativ
niedrig
richtig was meinen Sie warum die ganzen
Hermes und Amazon Sklaven weiter unsere
Pakete schleppen für 360 die Stunde aus
Spaß
weil die Todesangst haben in Hartz IV
abzurutschen so sieht's so aus
Ausbeutung und Putins billiges Gas waren
die Säulen unseres Wohlstands eine Säule
ist schon weg soll die andere auch noch
umkippen darüber könntet ihr links grün
Medien mal berichten statt Drogen zu
verherrlichen
die Berliner Grünen gelten als
progressivste Gruppe der doch
mittlerweile auch etwas alt spießigen
Grünen Partei
sagen Herr wenn du Cannabis reicht er
nicht
sondern da muss jetzt Kokain her und
Crystal Meth
wobei da muss ich jetzt zugeben gegen
ein zünftiges Christel Mettbrötchen
hatte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
sind du kannst Gedanken lesen wunderbar
warte mal
[Musik]
haben was und meine Posse Mama heißt
Leila sie schöner schöner
dürfte Schneider
so meine Damen und Herren
und dann gab es natürlich noch ein wenig
Aufregung wegen uns also wegen ARD und
ZDF die am vergangenen Montag wohl beide
über Stunden das gleiche gesendet haben
ja kein technisches versehen sondern
scheinbar Absicht Dietmar Wischmeyer hat
es trotzdem gefallen
wischmeyers Logbuch der Bekloppten und
bescheuerten
jetzt reicht's aber auch mal mit dem
ewigenörgel an den
öffentlich-rechtlichen ja ARD und ZDF
haben parallel von der Beerdigung der
Queen berichtet aber was wäre denn die
Alternative hätte die ARD an diesem
historischen Tag etwa Giraffe
Erdmännchen und Co senden sollen da darf
man von einem halbstaatlichen Medium
wohl etwas mehr Respekt erwarten
außerdem hat jeder Gebührenzahler einen
Anspruch darauf 9 Stunden 1A Begräbnis
Fernsehen zu glotzen ohne extra
umschalten zu müssen wir sehen jetzt
dass der Leichenwagen sich in Bewegung
gesetzt hat der Leichenwagen allein auch
der Leichenwagen den Leichenwagen der ja
extra für diesen Tag angefertigt worden
ist der hatte vor allem auch eine
Beleuchtung in auch mit einer
Beleuchtung und einer einer Glaskuppel
und da sehen wir ihn hier handelt sich
soweit ich sehen konnte hinten an der
Klappe um einen Jaguar jetzt ist ja
gerne Jago Gefahren wie der Kollege eben
auch sagte und nun hat sie einen eigenen
Wagen auch noch zum Schluss die Queen
lebte Hunde Pferde und sogar Menschen in
der Reihenfolge deshalb hat man die
Pferde verschont und vor die schwere
Lafette mit dem Sarkophag eine
Hundertschaft Matrosen angescherrt daran
können sich die Deutschen ruhig ein
Beispiel nehmen was aber machen wir noch
am selben Abend lassen verbiesterte
deutsche talkshow-figuren Häme
verbreiten es kann eine völlig absurde
Tradition ist ja dass zum Beispiel der
königliche Imker die Pflicht hat die
Bienen der Königin über den Tod ihrer
Majestät zu informieren ja und du hast
eine absurde Frisur aber das ist doch
auch okay
und warum soll man ausgerechnet die
Bienen weiterhin im Unklaren lassen das
macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn
es ist leicht sich über die Briten zu
markieren sie haben nicht genug
Klopapier füttern aber eine königliche
operettenfamilie durch heimlich geguckt
haben wir the Royal Begräbnis trotzdem
es waren ja auch alle da also außer die
die nicht da waren der prominenteste
nicht eingeladen ist sicherlich
russlandsstaatspräsident Wladimir Putin
der stand von vornherein nicht auf der
Liste es war auch aus dem Kreml zu hören
dass er eh nicht gekommen wäre
Kindergarten euch lande ich zu meiner
Beerdigung auch nicht ein
schöne Bilder eines insgesamt
unaufgeregten fernsehtages den uns ARD
und ZDF gemeinsam geschenkt haben
inmitten von Ukraine Krieg und
explodierenden Preisen für Katzenfutter
danke alte Tante öffentlicher Rundfunk
und das vorletzte Wort gehört wie immer
dem Bundespräsidenten wie erinnern Sie
sich an diese Begegnung wie haben sie
Queen Elizabeth in Erinnerung
sie war
wesentlich weniger steifer als ich mir
das gedacht habe
vielen Dank Frank Walter steiffmeier
wir freuen uns jedenfalls auf die
nächste parallelübertragung die Krönung
Charles des Dritten zu sehen in der ARD
dem ZDF allen dritten Programmen
tagesschau.de und natürlich eine Woche
vor der Live-Übertragung in ihrer
ZDFmediathek danke schön
[Musik]
oh Gott der Dreh für die